damn
all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel today
i'm in a new setup um
it's a little echoier because i haven't
soundproofed it yet
but
hi i'm getting ready for the live show
friday at 8.
um anyways today i am going to be
reacting to different content live so um
make sure this audio is working but yeah
i think so i'm going to be reacting
actually let me
let me mute out the other mics because
i make sure it's just this one okay
um
okay
anyways do not forget to subscribe to
the channel guys and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
also feel free to send me donations
i know it's like you know kind of tacky
to like ask for donations but
the reason being is i have four mics
right now and i really want to get to
eight um i'm gonna be doing our first
live show for the pre-game
um
on friday
and it's gonna be friday at 8 00 gmt
which i believe is like three o'clock
central
[Music]
three o'clock eastern time
2 p.m central
um okay so like let's look for a clip
that i'm gonna do today
you know i'm gonna do brony lee because
her fans are very funny they very much
enjoy her also let me know how the audio
sounds
am i taking requests yes i am
but i thought i saw this and i was like
god showed me why so many good women are
saying still single powerful message
30 minutes there cannot be 30 minutes of
reasons
why so many good women are single
interesting these are the
she uses
okay
um
we'll see if i watch this whole thing i
probably won't wait why can't i hear
it um
this might just be another problem that
i don't know how to fix yet
audio desktop audio
um
let me see
audio input capture
um
desktop audio
oh here we go
let's try this
again um
why can't i still not hear it i can hear
myself
does this not let me do that on the road
caster pro
oh my god guys every day a new problem
ah
why god okay hold up
oh my lord okay
30 minutes i know i'm like 30 minutes of
reasons there cannot be that many
reasons
um i just made my problem worse
okay
um
now i gotta figure out
um
okay did that change anything
uh
okay
um
let me try it again
odd
um
okay so desktop audio is going to be the
road caster pro
um maybe i'll just google this
sorry guys
i thought if i just plugged in the
headphones they would work
i stand corrected
okay wait let me go here actually and
see if it's these settings
um
sound
speaking and recording
virtual speakers
road connect it says road connect so it
should be the road
okay what about now let's try this
you're this person oh i can hear it now
yeah having to act like i don't want to
be
you guys hear it can you guys hear it
sorry guys
um
lemonade bet you are a great moderator i
was a little worried with you i'm not
gonna lie
i am pleasantly surprised with your
moderating abilities sir
um okay you hear it is the sound like
equal like can you hear it let me just
and the average guy sorry not sorry just
does not measure up
hey guys welcome back to my
channel hope you guys
are doing
all right how's the okay you hear it
okay okay
all right bernie lee
her fans are so adamant like they're
like you don't know anything you just
have low standards i'm like all of you
all sound
sick so in today's video we are talking
about something that god showed me
however i feel like it can pertain to a
lot of you guys and the analogy that i'm
going to show may pertain to a lot of
you guys as well before we get into the
video i want to thank better help for
sponsoring today's video so i want to
talk to better help sponsor me
i'm poor and i use you guys
i swear to god i use you guys those who
are maybe having a really hard time on
this channel we are talking about
leveling up and focusing on ourselves
and this concept for some people may be
very very difficult because you alone
cannot help yourself and it is so
daunting to watch everyone be so
optimistic what's the deal with being
worried with me um okay that it was
because you seem like a troll so that's
that's why i was worried i was like i
don't know if you're gonna be trolling
but
no you've been a great moderator like i
have nothing but great things to say
about your moderating abilities okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna stop composited about
the new year well you just feel lost
trust me i've been there but therapy
helped me a lot out of the dark hole
that i was in so if you are looking for
an online licensed therapist where you
do not have to leave the comfort of your
own home you better check out better
help
better help i actually use better help
and i actually enjoy them i know they
like give away your data but i'm someone
i just don't care
like i
yeah so if you don't care about your
data being shared better help i think
has actually been decent you can access
a network of over 20 000 licensed
therapist
responses plus you can schedule week
betterhelp.com forward so the woman that
we are speaking about in this video is
the excellent woman that we spoke about
in last week's video and i feel like
excellent women we have the hardest time
finding someone to love and be loved by
and it's not because there is something
wrong with us like these podcasts want
us to believe however it is that we are
so expensive that the average joe is
just not enough and i'm going to be
using
ah
oh gosh i already don't like this
ma'am ma'am
why why is women do we say
none of the guys i want want to date me
so the problem is them not me
look it
i'm gonna be honest i'm single you know
i'm newly single right
like there are things i could do to
improve
i'm really not like super looking for
anything right now
but if i was there were things i could
do to improve that like stop dressing
homeless all the time
maybe put in more of it like you know
what i mean like
i don't know i just i hate it when
people blame everyone else for their own
problems
like if you're single it's your problem
unless you want to be alone the rest of
your life then you know go do that in
some language in this video too small
expensive oh my gosh thank you 15
guys thank you so much oh my gosh i
don't know how to put the chat
on the on the screen in stream yards
otherwise i would i'm very sorry i'm
using um obs today not stream yards um
but i'm gonna figure it out but but
friday
but thank you so so much guys i've been
working so hard at this podcast
i'm very stressed i'm very stressed
especially about money i've spent
more money than i have right now getting
this going between buying like a new rug
new equipment outside of the donation
like it's been a lot but seriously every
single donation helps so much and i
swear to god i'm gonna put on a great
show i'm going to put on a great show
um also also
put in
the chat what topics we should cover
friday
because
i got a lot of ideas but i want to hear
what you guys want to talk about because
last time it was really just like a test
like i really wasn't trying to debate
anyone like
those girls were just there for like fun
okay like because you kind of have to
balance personal relationships and like
working relationships you know what i
mean but when when it's a show it's go
time gloves off
anyways so let me know in the chat what
you guys would want me to talk about
enough my audience you are women who are
high value women you are women of
substance you are women of quality of
value so i know it definitely won't
offend you but i know that there's going
to be men that are too small to even
comprehend what i'm saying and i ask
that you guys do not argue them in the
comments that you just take away what
you need to take away from today's video
and like i said we are not your average
woman we are women that know who oh my
gosh thank you for the two dollar super
chat thank you oh my gosh thank you guys
i swear to god
sometimes i could cry with all the
thanks
like with how grateful i am for all of
your donations i seriously seriously
appreciate it
debate you are you in london
i need a guy for friday because i have
three girls i want to get a guy so if
someone is in london i'm open to it we
are have been through enough trials and
tribulations come out on the other end
bigger and better we are women who are
healed or still healing we are women
that are aware of our value we know our
calling in life we know where we're
going in life we have goals we have
dreams we have vision we have ambition
we are women that just have that feeling
inside that we were called for something
bigger and better i relate to this
my whole life i have never
i've always felt the call to work
always and this is something
that's kind of tough as a girl because
it's not fun being with a guy that
you're like more driven and ambitious
than like that's that's not fun right
that's not that's something that's not
something any girl wants like we always
want a guy that look you look up to
but the problem is when you are very
driven and you work hard that's not
exactly attractive to a guy
um i think like guys appreciate that i
work hard but again as i've said to
other women
a guy isn't attracted to a ceo of a
company the same way we are when we see
a ceo of a company we think that's hot
when a guy says like sees that a girl is
a ceo of a company he thinks that's you
know cool you know he might appreciate
that she's like a hard worker or
whatever
but you know typically like the driven
men want women that are a little bit
more like feminine laid back and look at
i don't even consider myself like the
typical
you know stay-at-home mom type of girl
because i can like work long hours and i
i've always like taken pride in that
and i've always felt like a little bit
called to work does that make sense um
so it's not a fun reality guys but
but like we can't deny how the world is
that's that's just like how it is so
if we're gonna be more driven and work
hard that's fine but like you have to be
okay with a guy
that makes less than you if that's what
you want to do
um because those guys aren't looking for
us or aren't looking for you
yeah so
working hard in the home
yeah like like i'm just someone when
i've this is just personally when i've
like thought about my life i really want
to be super involved in my kid's life
like that that's a no-brainer but like
i would really love to outsource
cleaning oh my god i really i don't
enjoy it it's just not
i would like to make enough money that i
can hire cleaners i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay
um
if i can i will
i will
but guys like again
like figure out what comes with it
anyways
not in london i'm in dallas let me come
on virtually uh no
respectfully no um
maybe later that could be a different
i'm not i'm not going to figure out how
to get virtual guests on the channel by
friday
i don't got time for that
um i'm barely getting this equipment to
work so you don't know what it is we
just know that inside there's something
great for us to do and whether you are
famous or not people know your name or
not that like i've always felt the call
to like
i don't know to have a channel or like i
don't know like since i was really
little it's really hard to describe i've
always felt like i'm going to be known
and i i've never felt like i was gonna
be like a world superstar or anything
but i've always felt like
i was going to be in media in some way
and even like i switched my name my
first name is hannah my middle name is
pearl and when i was